no that the jets even though they didn't
win the rights to trevor lawrence they
hold the board after lawrence how likely
is it that they go
zach wilson or some other quarterback in
your view right like and again i want
i'm very early like i was supposed
tuesday i was really supposed to get
into the nitty-gritty and my film set up
in my house had a little issue so i'm a
little behind but philip what did philip
do well he there was there was like a
wire because he plays his video games
there too so there was like a wire loose
and i had to call the guy to figure it
out and we finally got it so so what i'm
throwing your child under the bus
you are ted cruz screw kids who the hell
needs them okay i mean yep uh so i was i
was pissed because i was planning on but
what i've done to this point just to be
totally transparent i've watched
basically what we call a poa in the nfl
world point of attack film they call it
just the good plays really i've only
seen good plays from zero pos film too
well i'm gonna get to that because of
course that's that's part of evaluating
these quarterbacks but
like i came away and as you heard me say
before zach wilson's got some really
really special traits i mean very
special he really does he's a phenomenal
athlete he's got great feet he's got you
know
imagination and creativity with how to
deliver the football which we know is so
important right now and and to me just
from what i saw there and again i don't
it's early but like i said that i was
pleasantly surprised that the gap was
much closer between trevor lawrence and
zach wilson than i expected i thought it
was going to be trevor lawrence clearly
the guy i came away just watching again
the positives going uh no it's it's not
just a slam dunk home run that he's
better than zach wilson wilson has some
really special things again and and and
i would think that the jets are gonna of
course see the same things i'm saying
and are going to certainly think about
all possibilities and i would not be
shocked if they went zach wilson listen
the fan base here in the jets area in
the new york area
and i know pete could speak to this too
they're not i don't think they're really
behind the sam darnold thing right now i
haven't given up on sam darnold
certainly i still think there's good in
his play and he could be something in
this league but you know
it hasn't worked here and do they want
with this new regime to have their own
stamp and their own guy going forward
and with their new offensive coordinator
that is here you know he might really
love the athleticism and some of the
imagination we talked about with zach
wilson wilson throws perfect spirals
every throw mike i mean it spins hard
like aaron rodgers hard or mahomes hard
where you go like am i seeing something
weird here is that an optical illusion
and there was more power in his arm than
i thought too so that's where it gets
interesting and uh they're gonna they're
gonna have a nice decision there they
got a lot of nice options where the jets
are sitting right now
and if i understand what the flow chart
should be for the jets step one is
analyze the quarterbacks and see if
there's one about whom you feel
sufficiently strongly to make him the
second overall pick in the draft i think
step two after that would be
make sure there's no one that's going to
make you an offer you can't refuse to
trade out of that spot the zack wilson
spot because that's the philosophical
discussion that we had last week as it
relates to trevor lawrence
what is your priority to have a guy who
could be a sure thing but you don't know
for certain
or a bunch of other lottery tickets you
could get for him are you going to get
an offer for zach wilson that you just
cannot refuse if you're the jets that
would be step two and then step three
once you decide you are taking the
quarterback with that pick that's when
you move sam darnold and get what you
can because you can't have both guys on
the roster no way if you're gonna take
the young guy you can't have the guy
who's still kind of the young guy who's
in the fourth year of his rookie
contract especially with a fifth year
option looming and i think i still need
to i need to put this on my list and
then get the answer to it i think this
is the first year that if you exercise
the fifth year option it's fully
guaranteed at the time it's exercise
right i need to remember i keep saying
that i'm going to look it up and i think
you're right i think this is the year it
becomes fully guaranteed so you want
darnold off your roster before may 3.
yeah that that makes sense and i think
you are right too i i uh well maybe you
can look that up but but
this that's a it's a big time decision
it really is you know matt lefleur
coming from kyle shanahan the 49ers
listen sam darnold certainly can play
that style of football there's no doubt
about it
you know play actions boots get on the
move do that type of stuff he's a good
thrower the football but you know he has
been injured too now i give him a little
leeway for him being injured as compared
to jimmy garoppolo jimmy garoppolo has
gotten hurt you know with great
supporting cast around him sam darnold's
been getting hurt with like as we've
talked about crap around them and when
you're around crap all the time it's
going to get on you and you're going to
smell like crap as we as i always say so
you know that that's where it's hard to
get a true picture of what he is
but i i i'm going to be really intrigued
with what they do here they have a ton
of money you know in the cap too of
course we know all the draft picks the
desean watson thing makes no sense to me
so i don't expect that to
hear that anymore because i mean they're
going to have to trade away everything
and the jets have needs
all over their roster i mean really
there's not really a position on their
team
that you can look at and go
they need upgrades they need receivers
they need running backs they need
corners they have no pass rusher you
know they have a lot of issues on their
football team so uh that's to me where i
don't think the sean watson thing
happens and we'll see if joe douglas and
robert sala and everybody can can get
this thing rolling
yeah i look i agree that that uh they
have a lot of areas to address douglas
has been trying to build the team from
the inside out focusing on the lines
that's the key offensive and defensive
line
um
let's one more hypothetical here okay
assuming they they go offensive linemen
with the second overall pick or address
other needs or whatever it is they don't
draft a quarterback in round one and
they stick with sam darnold
who would be the best backup for sam
darnold to help get him to where he
needs to be
as an nfl starter well
i mean listen the guy that you think
about all the time listen ryan
fitzpatrick is going to be out there
andy dalton is going to be out there
right they're going to be those guys
that certainly can help him and show him
the way a little bit he has had joe
flacco i've been around sam darnold i
think we've both talked to people in the
jets there's there's a lot that they
like about his approach to the game and
the things he brings to the table
there's no doubt about that
um you know really the only negative
i've ever heard about sam darnold really
is just you know maybe the juice and the
energy he could bring to the team or
maybe wish there was a little bit more
there some fire you know during the game
getting pissed off what the hell are you
guys doing all of those type of things
haven't seen that from him not that
that's a necessity to win in football we
know that but some teams do like that
you know the another guy i'll throw out
there you know would would be like a
mitch trubisky you know again too
not that he's going to be the guy you
learn from but for the jets standpoint
if they go with sam darnold and looking
for okay we need a backup because hey
sam darnold's gotten hurt and our team's
not quite where it's been trebrisky is
the type of guy too that i think could
run that shanahan matt lafleur type of
offense and have a little success and
not be a bad backup that way um but i
guess those are the names that jump out
to me right off the top of my head mike
yeah that would make some sense i think
though it's all academic my gut is you
know this is a team that's waited 50
years for its next joe namath yeah they
have an opportunity to get and they
tried it three years ago 2018 draft when
they moved from six to three to get
darnold it didn't work and what do you
always say hey you try it if it doesn't
work you'll be in a position to try it
again yeah sooner rather than later and
here they are in position to try it
again and maybe maybe they end up with
the better of the two long term maybe
zach wilson ends up better than trevor
lawrence we just don't know and we won't
know until they play a sufficient amount
of time in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports